I want to talk about how the state
encourages
um women to divorce men so this came
from a commenter uh by the name of Kim
Brown in one of my older videos probably
from about four years ago because I
wrote this because I published this book
two years ago
um she says in her comment okay talking
about a divorce video the thing that
infuriates me is my hubby makes about
fifty thousand dollars a year I make
about half that but when you're talking
to people about taking responsibility
for themselves you do realize that if I
were to leave my hubby and become a
single mother with government benefits
I'd have way more money follow me
through here what we pay in taxes is a
couple opposed to what the government
would give me if I was on my own isn't
even close okay I'm gonna say it again
she would be making more money as a
single mother leaving her husband than
what she does as a married couple let me
carry on through here
um
so when women leave the husbands they
are improving their situation until that
changes nothing else will it's sickening
when Society rewards those who make bad
choices so she's so she's pissed off
because one of her co-workers and
they're comparing notes uh revealed that
because they make the same money both
these two chicks make the exact same
money uh her husband makes 50 Grand but
the government tops up the difference
plus the alimony plus plus the child
support gives her more money than what
they have as a couple so she goes on to
say my friend who's a single mother who
does the same job and makes the same
money as me we sat down and compared our
finances and all the subsidies and tax
breaks she receives an income from the
exes uh and the government she has about
a thousand dollars a month more than my
family and disposable income so a single
Mommy
working the exact same job without a
husband in the house
getting all the support from Big Daddy
government Big Daddy X has about a
thousand dollars a month more than her
family and disposable income to me
that's not just rewarding single mommies
it's actively punishing middle to low
income women for staying with the father
of their children she's not wrong so you
have to understand guys the laws
incentivize women
to behave badly in a divorce situation
and it also incentivize women to leave a
marriage because they'll get more money
and not have to deal with his dumb ass
either right if you don't know this
there's been lots of research done on
this by the way but
the interest that you have in your
girlfriend boyfriend whoever it is that
you're with right now
for men it goes down but it goes down
very steady
over time
with women it's like a hockey stick it's
like almost like right from the get-go
from the honeymoon phase it's like
and then it kind of like goes down even
more after that okay so
you need to be captivating as [ __ ] if
you're a dude if you want to keep a
chick around
it's one of the Seven Pillars that I
talk about I did a podcast three four
months ago you can go back and look that
up but the seventh pillar is being
captivating essentially not being boring
anyway so the state encourages women to
get divorced so those are the four main
points if you want to get into the weeds
and really in the details just get my
book
um I'll link it below it's on Amazon
married men I don't know we can talk
about that or we can get into the blog
what do you guys want to do
I can get right into the weeds here
um
so
Now setting aside family law alimony
child support women are motivated by the
laws and by the government to leave
their husbands domestic violence all
that stuff another big problem is that
when men get into marriages things
change for men
and not for the better
so
before leading up to the divorce
[ __ ]
um there's generally a process of [ __ ]
testing consecutive [ __ ] testing if you
don't know what that is they're
basically competency tests where women
just
irritate men they nag them they do silly
things
um and they're really just trying to
test their competency as a man
scholarship test also known as
betatization through a thousand
concessions it usually starts with
something like uh honey you don't brush
your teeth over there you're going to
get toothpaste on the carpet to make
sure your white socks go in the white
hamper and your dark clothes go in the
dark camper to let's go vegan together
to Let's spice up the relationship and
invite a bull in so that uh I can cuck
you and you can sit there and watch so
bit of tization through a thousand
concessions it can go through a total
different number of sequence of events
but but it all ends in the exact same
spot
you don't look like an alpha tour
anymore you look like a beta male and
women are not attracted to Beta males
over a long term basis
so if you're not on your game if you
don't have strong frame in a
relationship you will go through
betaization it's not a question of if
you will it's to what extent okay
because even solid guys that write books
on this [ __ ] are going to go through
even a little degree of betaization
trust me
um let's go to married men reduce Sex
Drive is another big point
um one of the big complaints one of the
one of the most interesting here let's
let's go to Google and let's do it right
now
let's do it right now
how do I get my wife to
uh
where is the shadow stream there we go
so let's see what I don't know it's
already filled in
how do I get my wife too and then the
search results Love Me Again lose weight
so women that aren't that aren't in love
with their husbands women that have
become fat uh women that don't trust
their husbands women that don't respect
their husbands that's big how do I get
my wife to forgive me probably some simp
that like did nothing wrong that she's
brow beating him on to talk to me to
stop yelling at me to listen to me
I don't get my wife to show how do I get
my wife to listen to me how do I get my
wife to stop so
let's see here
let's try have let me see if it
recommend something
two come on
Google search give me some
adults baby not cooperating interesting
I wonder if uh what's that other sir is
it Duck Duck Go
we get here
see what dudes are searching for like
probably pre-populate like Google don't
they
how do I get my wife to feminize me holy
[ __ ] dudes are searching for that
are you kidding me
dude look at this
how do I get my wife to love me again
how do I get my wife to feminize me
that's brutal
man I thought [ __ ] was soy but that's
soy right there how do I get my wife to
want me again how do I get my wife to
admit she cheated
I don't get my wife to stop boozing lose
weight how do I get my wife to leave me
interesting
well one of the
most popular searches and I'm guessing
it's probably showing up on like
discussion forums is around sex a lot of
dudes are in sexless marriages too
lots of power is also huge as well
I mean if you're familiar with uh power
dynamics
um
women have a way through the betaization
process of
stealing leadership
from leaders right and if you're not
good with having a backbone you're going
to get destroyed
lack of power is a big thing too
um
you'd be appalled at how many girls have
confessed with me that they've had exes
who wanted to get pegged I used to think
that was a joke it usually leaves a
girl's traumatized you know what's funny
um
I think I'm going to do a podcast
because I have a bull in my group that
um
basically cucks dudes uh women on dating
apps convince their boyfriends or
husbands to invite a bull into the
bedroom and
um he tears it up that's that's one of
the things that he does
so I'm gonna throw some questions at him
and I'm gonna do a uh
a podcast I can't bring them on
obviously because
um
you know obvious reasons how do I get my
wife to cook a decent meal
yeah
how do I get my wife to leave me yeah
that was one of the more popular ones
towards the top but yeah oh by the way
uh somebody mentioned shirt if you guys
want uh this t-shirt it's in the it's
it's on the store tab
um if you go to the YouTube channel and
just go across to it's like Community
about this is like a store tap you can
grab this shirt over there
today's zfg day
no I I can't get them on the podcast uh
freelancer because
um
he doesn't want to lose the job
he doesn't want people to know that he's
a bull
um but yeah I will trust me I'll it's
gonna be a good one hey guys I really
hope that you enjoyed that short clip if
you did consider supporting the creation
of content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out